ces attaques inacceptables qui sont
dénoncés par madame liu malheureusement
elles semblent se multiplier
oui en fait il ya vraiment une tendance
plutôt inquiétante ces lignes j'ai
répertorié pour vous quelques unes des
plus récentes attaques
les deux premières en fait ont eu lieu
également en syrie contre des hôpitaux
le 5 février à quelques jours de cela
à tafas c'est dans le sud du pays c'est
près de la frontière avec la jordanie
et l'on ne sait pas à qui incombe la
responsabilité de ces bombardements est
ce que c'est le gouvernement assad est
ce que c'est la russie elle-même grand
point d'interrogation également aussi le
28 novembre 2015 cette fois ci dans la
ville de och
cela aussi est ce le gouvernement assad
qui a frappé c'est difficile de prouver
pour l'instant mais également d'autres
pays par exemple au yémen à haydan le 27
octobre dernier
et là c'est ce sont des forces de la
coalition arabe en fait qui ont frappé
ce gouvernement il essaye de déloger
certains rebelles qui étaient hostiles
au gouvernement du yémen
et aussi comment ne pas ne pas parler du
fameux le bombardement à koundouz en
afghanistan à l'hôpital en fait elle et
c'était une erreur des américains dont
barack obama s'est même excusé ce n'est
pas suffisant selon madame liu parce
qu'il s'agissait en fait d'un hôpital de
msf et puis regardez quand même des
chiffres assez inquiétant quand on
regarde les hôpitaux qui sont des cibles
d'attaquants syrie en fait entre mars
2011 novembre 2015 donc c'est le temps
de la crise la 336 attaques contre 246
médicaux c'est énorme évidemment et
madame vous en parlait il ya quelques
instants donc depuis le début de l'année
seulement déjà 17 hôpitaux dont 5 sous
la bannière de msf est évidemment ces
hôpitaux ne devrait en principe pas être
la cible d'attaqués
selon les règles du droit international
la convention de genève voilà la fameuse
convention de genève qui date quand même
de 1949 ya 196 signataires de cette
convention et l'article 14 ou stipule
vraiment garantit la protection des
sites médicaux en temps de guerre
alors est-ce que à ce moment là frapper
un hôpital c'est un crime de guerre bain
bien souvent il enquête mais qui est
menée par le pays entre guillemet
responsable ce qui veut dire que
finalement mais ça n'aboutit pas à grand
chose qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut avoir
à ce moment là la cour pénale
internationale est déposé une plainte
pour crimes de guerre mais là encore les
poursuites sont vraiment très très très
très rare et pourtant msf demande encore
la tenue d'une enquête indépendante
savoir ce qui s'est vraiment passé qui
exactement
absolument c'est l'idée en fait c'est la
fameuse commission
qui porte le nom commission
internationale humanitaire
d'établissement des faits s'était établi
en 91 dont un ami ou demande que ce soit
tenue dans le cas par exemple des
frappes américaines en afghanistan
contre l'hôpital de msf
mais depuis les 25 dernières années
nombre dans lequel est absolument 0 donc
ça ne débouche sera absolument rien et
c'est ce qui provoque la frustration de
msf et des autres organismes
et pendant ce temps-là billets des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
n'ont même plus accès à des soins dans
les hôpitaux qui ont été détruits c'est
à ces terres et merci frédéric tout
appris